the joggin experience what they want is
money you know I was reading the thing
about the head of Google and he makes
you know something like 2 million bucks
a year but if he hits these performance
goals over the next three years he
stands to rake in two hundred and forty
million dollars in stock she says I was
like well no wonder why they're ruthless
no wonder one who make these just no
wonder where they take down the slogan
don't be evil that was their slogan was
don't be ghosts don't be evil and then
they like what about for two hundred
forty million dollars I feel Italy yeah
good people will behave corruptly that's
what happens in Washington it's just a
bunch of birds lesyk said Washington has
become a special interest cesspool we're
good people if you want to get ahead you
got to figure out a way to be good
people must behave corruptly because
it's an economy but not all of them no
not all of them because if they were all
tore up there would be no reason to
suicide anybody there would be no reason
to bribe anybody there's good people in
there if you [ __ ] up someone's willing
to kill a [ __ ] just to avoid you
don't have to kill any more people you
just have to figure out which who are
the good people you don't kill people
anymore
you think people what a didn't Epstein
just commit suicide do you think Kevin
Spacey's killing people no you see that
new video that came out right before the
dude suicided himself that accused him
of grabbing his dick oh yeah before I
kill him with kind come on man oh really
he's doing this Frank Underwood you
haven't seen it no suicide like a week
later yeah that's what I'm talking about
the shit's going on and no one gives a
[ __ ] we don't have time nobody gives a
[ __ ] sure you do no no you just you just
destroy the reputation
Brian slow down if your reputation has
already destroyed though like Kevin
Spacey and there's a guy claiming that
you grabbed his dick might be a good
idea to kill him watch this a little bit
give me some volume on to go to prison
dude that's all you gotta avoid this in
a pretty good year and I'm grateful to
have my health
and in light of that I've made some
changes in my life cycle dude he's
MKULTRA you think so
more good in this world oh yes
I know what you're thinking can he be
serious I'm dead serious and it's not
that hard
trust me the next time someone does
something you don't like you can go on
the attack but you can also hold your
fire and do the unexpected
you can kill them with kindness Wow dude
he put that out and everyone is cool he
didn't kill he died a few days later do
hear what he just said and do you know
what he's in the middle of that's not
it's not like hold on Eddie let me hold
on before we hey B hey B do you think
attorney do you think yep Simon was
committed suicide or was murdered I
don't know what I think I totally
believe you
he would kill himself why would he want
to be alive where is he gonna go I mean
he committed suicide it's very possible
yeah
how many guys from Kevin Spacey what are
you showing me Jay what's going on
December 26 yeah that video was posted
on the 24 dude
but here's the thing though that means
the guy saw it for two days so for two
days he probably on a loop watch this
video this guy who grabbed his dick
he's like why didn't I just punch him uh
bang yeah but to me it was like as he
grabbed his dick he said lot more issues
and grabbed his dick and said let's go
outside and get some air that's it yes a
whole other life yeah there's a lot of
people kill themselves that never got
the dick graph like Kevin Spacey right
but so the thing is this guy killed
himself
two days after Kevin Spacey released
that video this could easily just be a
coincidence it could easily be that the
type of guy that Kevin Spacey grabs the
dick they're probably not doing so good
in the first place what was it
young when he grabbed that day well this
uh I don't know this is a different one
there's many few he was aggressive with
the dick wrap I didn't know he's gay the
thing about it man here's the thing
about it it had to have worked if he
grabbed that many dick I'll do how many
yes cuz they don't know knows everybody
so homophobic lame homophobic people on
Kevin Spacey out there gravity hit I got
moves me as much of a monster rapist as
Harvey Weinstein is as much of a [ __ ]
made some good not he [ __ ] he [ __ ] a
whole lot that all that yes that word
that allowed it was consensual
these boys took ice creams had a lot of
home runs yes a lot of home yeah there
they had their bag of tricks that's why
Kevin Spacey felt like you could grab
dicks cuz it worked before act because
there's probably some thrilled
heterosexual guy who can't believe he's
got Kevin Spacey's [ __ ] in his mouth I
can tell anybody sir Wow celebrity
doesn't cut through your heterosexuality
you understand it does for a really
surprised dumb person would have kissed
I might have kissed Tom Cruise on the
mouth just because I was talking for an
hour and a half and I wanted to be his
friend so badly
dude that was it it makes if you're
really really dumb a super smart gay guy
could talk you into blowing them bit
whereas always I said I'm always
suspicious of bisexuals because every
single one of them I've ever met was a
[ __ ] and I have a theory I don't
believe it's really bisexual I think
there's gay dudes and then there's
really gullible straight dudes who get
talked into blow and crafty gay dude dan
worth the words a great [ __ ] talking
to anything and then all of a sudden
like I'm by definitely by there's a
spectrum of his people that don't
there's people that are asexual they
don't give a [ __ ] about so guys yeah
this is my friend of mine knew a guy who
who would be like I'll [ __ ] it I'll [ __ ]
anybody yeah what are you talking like
us
show me the money you put money on the
table there's not there's not a man or a
woman I wouldn't [ __ ] yeah but that's
money guys a [ __ ] yeah hi and I'll let
anybody [ __ ] me okay what cost more I
needed the money
but what cost more getting [ __ ] or
[ __ ] someone because if you [ __ ]
someone you got to get it up hard
there's a heavy [ __ ] you know you wonder
you want to [ __ ] me that's another 200
see me not practically Brian practically
no condom another so it's two days I see
the fight listen listen listen what
would be what would be harder to do
would it be hard to have a guy or get
[ __ ] by guys oh good question
I don't it's a terrible question I think
you should get [ __ ] by a guy unless
you're gay but if you weren't gay
getting [ __ ] now might be easy I agree
you had a hard dick you could always say
my dad saw you [ __ ] in the I don't
give a [ __ ] guy [ __ ] you want to [ __ ] my
[ __ ] shoot I know I know a fighter who
will remain nameless who said he said we
were talking about his he was with his
wife and they were talking about
cheating and stuff and he said tell him
tell him what I do tell him what I do
know his wife goes hey tell him what
you'd do if you caught me cheating any
good she goes now tell him he guys oh
yeah I would
there's a reason I have viagra and
there's not because I need it for her
and I go well do tell now I'm all ears
and he goes well I would take viagra and
I would get my dick hard and I would
[ __ ] him in the ass
and it takes 45 her high whatever this
guy's a beast is to use all eight knows
who it is and I was just like you are
amazing and he was dead serious
I'll tell you it is that's an
interesting way to approach a private
you could guess
yeah okay we'll talk later yeah
do-do-do-do-do very impressive
[Applause]